hi there what you're seeing here is the
game Montezuma's Revenge and it has been
a problem for a long time for
reinforcement learning algorithms what
you can see is this little person that
has to kind of jump around collect keys
can collect these coins kind of get over
enemies and so on and all of this is
super hard because the reward is so
sparse so sometimes you have to do
hundreds of actions until you get the
next whatever improvement in score you
can see on the top how your score is
increasing and it seems like this
algorithm is pretty efficient on this
but keep in mind this algorithm has to
learn from just the pixel input it has
to learn every single move of the agent
so if you see here for example jumping
over the the enemies stopping when these
blue bars come and going down the
ladders without hitting the spider this
is really really hard problem and so far
reinforcement learning algorithms have
had a very hard time doing this until
this algorithm showed up go explore
which was the first one that actually
surpassed I believe human experts or
widely surpassed human experts at this
game in fact the first reinforcement
learning algorithm that without human
demonstration could do anything at all
at this game so let's dive in and see
how this algorithm does what it does and
the paper - this is called go explore a
new approach for heart exploration
problems by Atalaya
a Kofi Yost will quiz Inga you're a
layman Kenneth Oh Stanley and Jeff clone
from uber AI Labs so they they break
down the problem into what they call two
problems so these hard exploration
problem they say they suffer from two
things detachment and derailment you can
see here detachment and derailment so
they explain those in in detail
detachment and derailment are related to
each other
detachment is when an exploration
algorithm that has some sort of
intrinsic motivation right this is how
you usually do this hard exploration
problem
you give intrinsic motivation to the
agent to explore new things like in
absence of a reward if there is no
reward around it should just reach some
kind of new state and you give the
algorithm points for reaching states
that it has never seen before but this
can come to this sort of detachment
problem and if they illustrate this here
so let's say your algorithm starts
actually here in the middle right and
everything that's green here is our
intrinsic reward so you collect the
green stuff that gives you points right
so the goal might actually be in here or
in here but you have to teach the
algorithm to go all this way around and
you do that by simply motivating it to
go to new states by giving it a reward
for every state it hasn't been so it
starts exploring goes here then maybe
the first episode it reaches here right
before it is reset usually reset after
well like it bounces Kenda round is like
ah there's new stuff and then it goes
here and it will explore kind a bit and
it will be motivated to explore because
there's always this green stuff here so
after a while here whatever is purple
has been explored right recently so with
purple day mark but has been recently
explore all of this has been recently
explored right so it is gone until here
but usually you also have like a
component that isn't purely seeking this
green stuff but is also doing some kind
of a random exploration and so what
happens what can happen in these
algorithm is that if you at one of these
times you start the episode here by
chance it actually goes into the other
direction
alright and then it's like wow there's
all this green stuff over here right and
then it's like
so much green stuff right and then what
usually happens is kind of forgets that
there's green stuff over here it so it
explores all of this stuff around here
it explores explores explores about
there's no more stuff and then it's
stuck right
it's stuck here and it says where where
am I gonna go like I know over here
there's no more green stuff and over
here that doesn't appear to be any green
stuff because it's forgotten about about
this so this they claim these intrinsic
motivation algorithms what they can lead
to is you can detach from your frontier
of new knowledge right like they can
forget that there is that that here at
one point they were here and the
algorithm what the the algorithm did it
was it explored here until here and then
it explored over here so it thinks that
this thing over here is its most recent
frontier of knowledge right this is this
is my state here this is where I go
explore from but there's nowhere to
explore from right what it should
remember is that here it actually kind
of jumped over by random chance now this
makes sense this is called detachment of
intrinsic motivation algorithms and it
happens when you when you kind of give
these points according to simply
reaching new states and then another
thing it is what they call derailment
and derailment is a bit of a more subtle
problem
so in derailment what happens is maybe
you maybe you've actually let's say this
same situation you've discovered a
promising state right by some miracle
here is the goal right you've reached
the goal you've you've done this by
exploration you've explored a bunch and
you've reached the goal now the problem
is can you do it again right especially
if the environment is a bit stochastic
right if there is noise if the
environment isn't always the same
you actually learn how to do this
robustly like such that you can repeat
your success and in derailment is the
problem that often these algorithms
while they find promising things they
kind of struggled to robustly reach
those promising states go explore solves
these problems in in two separate phases
one for each basically so what it does
is in a phase one it explores right
explore and and is a crucial part until
solved so this is an exploration method
that explores until the problem is
solved with the focus on explore right
and then in stage two robusta phi and by
robusta v means that if stage one has
resulted in trajectories that have
solved the game over that the
environment then phase two is simply
task with robustly finding those so
let's look at phase 1 phase 1 is kind of
like think of Dijkstra's algorithm so in
Dijkstra's algorithm this is a shortest
path algorithm in in graphs so indexers
algorithm you have a graph and you want
to reach this from the start
let's call this the start and this is
the end or the goal and the graph is
connected with with edges and these
edges have usually sometimes they have
weights we can simply the goal is how to
go the shortest path from start to the
end and what Dijkstra's algorithm does
it is it starts exploring so it's like
it goes here alright and that says ah
this is a new state I reach the state in
one step
all right and explore some more I reach
this state in two steps and then it's
like I reach this state in three steps
ok but I can also go here I reach this
state in one step in two so I've already
been here okay but then it can you can
say ok from here I reach
stayed in - this is a bad example let's
say we actually have to make a shortest
path that this is the graph right so it
reaches this state in two steps but then
it explores this thing is like ah wait a
minute I've seen this state but before
I've reached it in two steps now I'm
reaching it in one step this is better
so this path here is better than this
path here and then it goes on from here
it goes on it says okay I'm reaching
this goal in two steps
I've reached it in three steps before so
clearly this bottom path here is better
than what I've done before this top or
this path so this is this is what go
explored us in a nutshell what it does
it has an archive of states right our
kind of states that it has visited
previously and the crucial thing here is
and this is kind of necessary to their
algorithm that there this is completely
deterministic so what they actually do
is they will save the state of the game
emulator right they they they they are
here right and they do some exploration
or jumping some until their their person
is here their game is in some state and
they will save the emulator emulator to
a buffer this is kind of crucial such
that at a later point they can select
this this exactly this state that they
were in and from here run a bunch of
explorations again right so if they say
select state from archive and then it go
to that state this is simply restoring
the emulator state but you could also
what you could also do if if this is a
purely deterministic environment you
could simply save the sequence of
actions that you've done to come here
and simply buy so maybe you gone right
right
and here you jump you go right you can
simply replay those to get to the exact
same state they discussed that this can
be expanded to also handle the kind of
stochastic environments but in their
case at the phase one
the environment is completely
deterministic so they can do this they
can go sorry they can go to a state
deterministically so they'll select a
state from an archive they have an
algorithm for selecting kind of
promising states they go to that state
and then they explore from that state
and they'd simply do this random so this
is random and then they update the
archive so what do they do
right we saw so here may be a new graph
so they go to a state this is their
state and then they explore now there
there are multiple things that can
happen
one they can encounter a new state right
new state never seen before
all right what they do is they save it
to the buffer it's say okay this new
state let's call it n this new state
I've reached it in and here we have done
s steps I've reached an S plus 1 step
and whatever here is the the emulator
state that we had before right so I can
at any point I can go back if however
this state has already been seen let's
call this M they retrieve M M Prime from
the buffer because they've already seen
it in the buffer right they compare
hey these steps so is s prime is this
smaller or larger then s +1
so basically I've seen this state before
but using this path can I reach it in
fewer steps than I've reached before if
yes then I'm going to replace this all
right replace this s by s plus 1 and
then save it again in the buffer all
right so I can I can I now have a better
path to reach this state than before so
it's almost exactly like Dijkstra's
algorithm and that you simply explore
and every new state you find you follow
either already C so you just simply have
a new way of getting to that state if
you haven't seen it you simply remember
it and then you do it all again so you
can you can imagine with time these
number of states and this buffer will
explode and it's not feasible for
Montezuma's Revenge like he imagined
this game right you have to you have to
go everywhere and explore everything
right this I mean every single action
here could be a state that's why let me
pause this that's why what they do is
they they have to come up with a notion
of state that is doesn't simply include
every single game state there is and
what they do is this is sent with your
take down sample the image and then this
sorry
I've tried drawing over a blog post they
down sample the image and then they
simply say all right so this this thing
would become this thing and they simply
say okay if two of these images have the
same representations of greyscale
downsampled quantized then they are the
same state and that's kind of the crux
of the algorithm I find so if two things
have the same state then the algorithm
is prone to kind of confusing them for
each other if things one is the other
not exactly but it it does kind of
assume that that they are close actually
here but if there is a crucial
difference between the two the algorithm
will have a very hard time in some
situations I don't want to like you can
think of it needs to be kind of
convoluted situations but it can be the
kind of crux of the algorithm very much
if the state representation isn't done
well and they actually have two methods
one simply relies on this down sampling
and the other one they provide domain
knowledge which means kind of which
level you're in where the player is and
so on but this is this is pretty cool
so if you are able so if if your
reinforcement learning problem for
first of all is deterministic mystic at
least in a simulator and second allows
for good state representations can
happen for for low dimensional state
representations if those two things are
given you can use go Explorer and as I
said this this representation here is
key so now you know how they do it they
simply explore these states and if they
come on a new state and every state is
so we don't mean this here we actually
mean this representation of it they
store it and they remember how to get to
it and simply by exploring like this and
having a smart algorithm that picks
which state to explore from which of
course is also a lot of domain knowledge
they are able to solve the game right so
you see it goes way past human expert
and they are they're able to to actually
perform really well simply by exploring
this is the exploration phase this is
simply random exploration from promising
states and then in the second part in
the second phase
they now robusta Phi it so now they
introduce noise into their environment
right because usually environments have
noise or some sort of stochasticity and
they run imitation learning on the best
trajectories they found and what that
does is what what they do is they have a
trajectory and let's say so this is a
trajectory right these are actions you
need to to reach this goal state this
imitation learning element what they do
is they take a few steps back say here
and they just use imitation learning
which is basically a form of
reinforcement learning to reach the goal
state from here simply reach the goal
state right once an under noise right so
you can't just take the exact same
action
once this has been learned back up a few
more steps maybe here and then try to
reach the goal state now you've already
learned how to do this part so this this
bigger part should become should be
easier than simply starting from here
and you do that until you've kind of
backed up your entire trajectory this is
a well-known method from imitation
learning but usually you have usually
this red thing is a human demonstration
but now this red trajectory has been
found by go explore it turns out if you
have a bunch of these trajectories from
go explore you can do a pretty good job
at that
all right that's basically all that I
wanted to say about go explore it's
basically Dijkstra's algorithm it works
under very specific circumstances but I
think it's super promising and it's kind
of a new way of thinking about it
so the video I've shown is actually go
explore solving montezuma's revenge
getting like a new high score and you
can see how like skilled this this
algorithm becomes alright with that I
say goodbye and hope see you next time